hey I'm Kevin he and Kieran hey I'm
Jason and there are new episodes of
draw-off on the way but today we're
gonna try something a little bit
different today we're gonna be drawing a
stranger based only on their voice so
how you guys feel about that
so everyone please welcome our stranger
for today her name is Chelsea hi nice to
meet you over voice nice to meet you so
Chelsea just to confirm we've never met
you've never met anybody here today
right
nope I know who you are only because of
your cool drawings but we have never met
okay so here's how it works
Chelsea you can't see our screens we
can't see each other's screens so the
only way that we need to know what to
draw is by what Chelsea tells us
first things first Chelsea just so we
avoid any type of awkwardness can you go
ahead and tell us your preferred
pronouns and also your ethnicity
I go by she her and I am Jewish okay so
it's just kind of free for them at this
point you guys can ask any whatever
questions you want Chelsea what does
your hair look like like what texture is
your hair will say hair is long do you
smile a lot is I do you like a really
happy person yeah yeah well these are
two very different questions James and
whether I smile or not has nothing to do
with my happiness okay your hair do you
usually wear up or down definitely down
okay how would you describe your
eyebrows I would say there's a lot of
eyebrow happening as in bushy or is
likely well if I started off with one
that day one now we do have two at the
moment I would say a prominent eyebrows
whatever that yeah all right Chelsea
tell us a little bit about yourself
where are you from I'm originally from
the Bay Area in a town called Novato
when you're not having strangers draw
you via your voice what do you what do
you like to do
I enjoy stand-up comedy that's really
fun
I also volunteer as a grief counselor
I'm pretty active in that space helping
younger girls when they lose a parent or
sibling specifically Wow
yeah so you help people sometimes that's
very normal
Chelsey you promise not to be offended
by whatever we draw right we not oh yeah
disclaimer I think this is super
interesting I absolutely respect the
artistry of this I do not have
expectations of it being a certain way I
think this is really cool and funny so
no hard feelings at all okay thank you
what type of clothing are you doing
we're just so strange I don't normally
talk about myself in this way but I'm
kind of feeling connected this like the
most connected I've felt to anyone all
day thanks guys I I wear clothes that
are loud I would say oh I like bright
fun stuff how would you describe your
nose you just ask that to a Jewish
person Jalen hey I'm trying to like
protect myself and get their answer at
the same time this is amazing you're
doing great okay it's not you it's not
Superboy D now I have to make a choice
about clothing you know what I'm going
crazy
I'm just gonna do something wacky it's
just the outfit that you're wearing now
I'm such an panic mode I think don't
know what to draw you how its drawn I am
like oh my god I want to start my
drawing from the beginning again that'll
have enough time this is way harder than
you draw off this is hard oh my god I
want to start from scratch I don't like
white drew really gonna start over I'm
one of us I'm gonna start over I'm
probably gonna be really late on this
but we'll see what happens
Jason I believe in me how would you
describe the shape of your face
I would say definitely oval oh no really
oh boy okay no I just I gave you more of
a heart-shaped face oh boy oval okay all
right all right I feel like I'm too far
in at this point so I think I'm just
gonna go with the heart shape Chelsea
when you smile do you do a toothy smile
or like an open mouth smile definitely a
lot of a lot of teeth like oh man okay
oh god a lot of hair so I'm giving you
pronounced but also very well taken care
of
eyebrows I really shouldn't have said
anything you're gonna be like it
no they're just eyebrows but that's like
interesting because like I feel like we
ourselves will like I can focus on a
certain part of our face then other
people won't notice that at all right
true yeah
something we think is like a huge deal
other people I like with the autonomy
walls so Chelsea when you wear your hair
do you part it on the side or down the
middle or how do you part it a side part
it slightly to my right long thick dark
hair curled pulling up these girls it's
not my hair isn't like frizzy like it's
straight but but I usually curl it okay
girls we do do curls I'm not too far
gone that I can't do curls Chelsea what
is your favorite shape of earrings
whoo thanks Chelsea what color your eyes
brown okay so complexion almond shades
and ice cream let's go vanilla I'm not
like super pale but I'm not sunkissed at
this time what are you wearing right now
Oh Jason
right now I am wearing black overalls
with a floral shirt
okay okay I'm not totally far off what's
your favorite color
oh good question pink and blue I have a
one more question is you're either black
or brown or like a dark brown it is
chocolate browns chocolate brown milk
milk chocolate or I'm insane I would say
dark chocolate dark chocolate okay this
is so exciting this the most emotions
I've felt in months
thank you all right Jason how you doing
you know what this can be done I mean
it's done
like I'm said it's done but like I can I
can fuss with this forever all right
yeah me too
all right so pens down the Chelsea we
are done with our drawings so the only
thing left to do is to turn your camera
on reveal your face I'm scared I was so
I'm so I'm in another stratosphere I
actually think I did pretty all right my
drawing looks nothing like you I think
the only thing I got good about right
about you is your eyebrows well no
matter what they are this is amazing I
think they're all really accurate wow
these are great you guys did a great job
whoa you guys are so good I feel like
those all literally look exactly like me
like if I was a cartoon I feel like I
would definitely be these three girls or
at least ten out with them so Jason I
feel like you're giving me the hair that
I think I have in my mind okay Kyra I
love her this is
so you is she's like very playful I
think like that is also something I
would wear or sure and have a knife like
that looks so much like me the specifics
of the finish I feel like really do
match my face for sure well Chelsea
thank you for being our first testing
person this was so fun need you so much
this may my quarantine so much better
let us know what you think in the
comments and be sure to follow draw-off
on instagram to find out how you may be
our next stranger
[Music]
[Music]